My name is Amar Dutta and I have
accepted Islam this Ramadan.  I am a big
fan of yours and I have accepted Islam with true intentions
and heart.  My question is whether it is necessary for Zakir
Bhai to get circumcised to accept Islam
or not?
Brother,
MashaAllah, in this Ramadan, Allah guided
him and accepted the religion of peace.
I pray to Allah Sun Taala that He accepts
your struggle, Insha Allah.
Inshallah you will be successful in this world and the hereafter too.
Your question was that when a non-
Muslim becomes a Muslim, accepts Islam, is it
necessary to get circumcised or not?
Circumcision when a person becomes a Muslim is
not obligatory but it is Sunnah Occidental It is
not obligatory but it is Sunnah Occidental or it
is a very important Sunnah It is recommended
because there are many reasons why you probably know that
after the progress of science, today science
says that when a child is born.
If he is circumcised after birth,
he has very little chance.  Carcinoma of
the
penis.  There is a very low chance of getting cancer of the penis.  There are
many diseases like this.  There are
many diseases which cannot be transmitted to
the boy or man due to circumcision.
For example, there is
the purpose which is there.  Because of that it may get
stuck in the zip.  They can be a problem
with it.  Further more, today's research also says
that a person who has undergone circumcision has
less chances of getting AIDS.  There are many such researches.   If
you listen to my cassette about science.
In this I have explained in more detail why
circumcision was asked in Islam.  So it is the
Sunnah of Mohammad Salla Wasallam that circumcision should be done, it is a
very important Sunnah, it is
very good if one does it but it is not compulsory in Islam.
Hope to answer the question
in mic number three, if you have any question then you
can ask it brother Assalamu Alaikum Doctor Zakir Nayak saheb, my name is Nilesh Ambhore, I have come from Aurangabad, my question to you is this sir, when you say something by quoting any Hindu Gita or Veda or if it is found in Quran, then can we act on it,
brother's question is that when I
quote Gita, I quote Vedas, I
quote other religious books.
When it matches the Quran, can we
act on it?  Should we talk about the Quran or the Vedas
or the Gita?  Of Geeta or Veda
?  Geeta or Veda.  So, can we follow what is
written in the Vedas and the Gita and what is found in the Quran
?  What I mean to say is
that the Quran is called
Furqan.  Furqan means that thing which recognizes the difference between truth and falsehood.
Furqan means difference.  The Quran recognizes the difference between truth and falsehood.  Just as
I said that many
prophets had come before Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, in the same
way it is written in the Quran in Surah Rad,
Surah number 13, verse number 38, that we have
revealed a book in every era.
Only four books are mentioned by name.
Torah, Zabur, Injil and Furqan Quran.
But many books have been revealed according to this verse.
He is not mentioned by name
in the Holy Quran.  But all the books that
came before the Holy Quran were for only one Ummah.
One was for Groh.  And that whole message
was limited to a time.
That is why Allah Subhana Taala did
not consider it right to keep all these books safe.  Because it was limited at that
time.  That is why the book that was
revealed earlier is not safe.  Nor is there any
need for that.  But because Quran Majeed
is the last word of Allah Subhana Taala.  That is why
Allah Subhana Taala himself says in Surah Hijr,
Surah number 15, verse number nine, that we have
revealed this Quran Majeed and we will
protect it.  So all the
books that came before have been adulterated.
The way Allah says in the Quran
Majeed in Baqarah, Surah number two, verse number
79,
Sumladi,
curse on those people
who write the book with their own hands and
say that it is from God.  Shame on those who
earn.  Shame on those who
write.  So, this shows
that all the earlier books have been adulterated.
This Quran is the last Kalam and no
one can change it even if they want to.
God himself, Allah himself will
protect it.  That is why today when I study the
Quran and other religious books,
if this matches, if whatever is said
in the Quran and the Bhagavad Gita is true, I have
no complaint in believing that this
portion, this verse is from God.
But if it does not match with the Quran then I
would say that it may be possible, it may not be possible.  But if it is
against the Quran then I can say that
this is not the word of God.  That is why whatever words we
get from the Quran, be it a shloka or a
mantra, from the Vedas, from the Upanishads, from the Gita, from the
Dhamma Pat, from the state, from the
Dasatir, from the Old Testament, from the
New Testament, whatever we
get from the Quran, we Muslims should not have any complaint
that this part, this part is from
God, that is why when I
talk about Yasaniyat,
I say to you also that leave aside the matters of disagreement.
The matters of individuality
which are written in your book, in the Vedas,
in the Puranas, that the last prophet is
Muhammad Sallallaho Wasallam, then it is your
duty to believe in this last prophet.
So you believe in the last prophet?
Yes.  Do you believe in your Vedas?   Yes, I
agree.  Do you believe in the old?
Yes, I agree.  So in my speech I
said so many times and quoted so many times that it is
written in your religious books that Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam is the last sage.  If you
read Kalki Purana, his father's name is written as
Vishnu Yas Abdullah, his mother's name is
written as Abdullah.  Sumati Amna where will he be born
?  In Mecca in Sambhal.  He was the chief of the
Quraish clan.
I said everything.  So now you believe that the
last prophet is Muhammad (peace be upon him)?  Yes, I
agree, right?  As
God willing.  So you believe that God is one?   Yes,
absolutely.  You believe that there is no idol of God.
Of course.  And one should worship only God.
Correct.  So you
believe that there is one God and Muhammad (peace be upon him) is the
last prophet.  So the person who
believes that there is only one God and that Muhammad (peace be upon him) is
his last prophet, we
call him a Muslim in Arabic.  That
is, the person who achieves peace
according to his desire of Allah Kemat.
So you believe that Allah is one and Muhammad (peace be upon him)
is the last prophet, then do you want to
accept Islam?
La ilaha illallah Mohammad Rasoolullah Mashallah Mashallah Mashallah
Subhan Allah, I have
told you verbally that Allah is one and there is no
god worthy of worship except Him and
Mohammad Salla Wasallam is the last prophet, you are a
Muslim, the way you asked the question
I was doubting whether Mashallah you
are a believer and I pray to Allah Subhana Taala
that Insha Allah Insha Allah may he give you
success in this world and the hereafter.